Thank You director whole and I couldn't
start this without indicating my
enormous debt to the ice on our library
and their staff who have helped me this
book could not have been written without
them there's many people to thank this
morning wonderful collaboration of the
ice power in the clinton library in
museums the Herbert Brownell memorial
lecture series the brown ale families
Brando that was here and we talked in
and brownell slow herb herb Ella's
daughter will be doing some of the panel
mothering later and above all William
Coleman who made some of this history
and is honored that we're honored to
Bill that you were here with us and he
encouraged me a lot as we started this
project and I have some classmates out
there some schoolmates classmates have
come to have a big party in a little
rock and I stupidly listen to this I
think they must end of the agenda I
don't know about anyone barring another
911 it's hard to imagine the President
of the United States any troops into an
American city to enforce the law but
that's what dwight d eisenhower did 50
years ago on sep tember 24 1957 for
decades I snares detractors and even
some of his admirers have propagated the
myth that he did not support brown v
board of education the Supreme Court's
1954 school desegregation decision that
struck down the separate but equal
doctrine from the 1896 decision in
plessy v ferguson but those critics are
confronted with the monumental fact of
Ike's intervention in Little Rock to
support a federal court order based on
brown eyes and harvest serious conflict
even civil war by sending troops into
our former Confederate state for the
first time since reconstruction now I've
attempted in this book to look over
Eisenhower's shoulder as he made that
decision and we are here today in this
observance because of courageous
decisions made by Dwight Eisenhower and
his wonderful attorney general Herbert
Brown then I regret that my focus on the
White House will not do justice to the
brave african-american students who
integrated Central High School and also
when we get to the riots in Little Rock
I ask your forgiveness when I quote some
racial opportunities the mob screens
those students while the n-word is that
no no these days it was not for many
people in 1957 and we need to avoid
getting so immersed in the politics that
we forget what those students indoors
but the politics is what we're about
this morning biographer Stephen Ambrose
declared the Eisenhower was quote no
leader at all in civil rights but please
consider these facts eisenhower and
partnership with attorney general
brownell appointed civil rights
advocates to the Justice Department
desegregated White House staff
desegregated the District of Columbia
combated discrimination and government
employment and government contract and
completed the desegregation of the armed
forces that Harry Truman had begun
including federally controlled schools
for military dependents please note that
he did that before the brown decision
Ike engineered the passage of the first
civil rights legislation in 82 years and
secured additional voting rights
legislation in 1960 above all Eisenhower
was a fierce defender of the courts and
as we revealed his decision to send
troops to little off Little Rock please
note how often he declares his purpose
is to defend the Constitution as
interpreted by the federal courts and of
course the main way he defended it was
with his appointments he appointed five
men to the Supreme Court all of whom
were pro-civil rights program and
numerous courageous judges to the
federal courts to himself in short in
the 1950s please note this is the 50s
not the 60s Dwight Eisenhower was more
on civil rights then harry truman john f
kennedy or lyndon johnson especially in
his support of the court in little rock
above all was about a federal court
order on September second 1957 governor
orval faubus of Arkansas ordered units
of ease arkansas national guard to
surround Central High School in Little
Rock and prevent nine african american
students from entering the school at his
news conference the next day Eisenhower
professed ignorance about the situation
and said he had returned the matter to
the Attorney General a favorite dodge
when he did not want to discuss a hot
issue on sep tember for attorney general
brownell was the president's approval
public would warn governor Faubus that
quote the president could use federal
troops or the National Guard units of
any state to enforce the court order
federal judge ronald Davies ordered
Little Rock school officials to ignore
the National Guard and perceive of
desegregation when the nine students
attempted to enter the school on
September third the soldiers walked
their way while crowd of 400 men and
women cheered food enchanted 10 4 6 8 we
ain't gonna integrate tall armed
soldiers blocked Elizabeth Eckford from
later in school 50 protesters closed in
get er get the [ __ ] out of here hanger
black ass they shouted a man chased
melba pattillo under mother's peace the
girls sleeve and shouted they're getting
away the [ __ ] are getting away a man
toward Torah Melba's my loose blouse and
another close to the growth swung
occurred with a large tree branch but
mrs. Melba and her mother jumped into
their car drove away the man pounded on
the hood in another threw a brick at the
windshield the Eisenhower's had just
begun their vacation in newport rhode
island on sep tember fifth with Governor
Faubus mr. president and angry telegram
accusing federal authorities of tapping
his phone and plotting to arrest him
Eisenhower's response with bruk quote
when I became president I took an oath
to support
defend the Constitution of the United
States the only assurance I can give you
is that the Federal Constitution will be
upheld by me by every legal means at my
command legal means obviously meant
troops on Monday September 9th judge
Davies asked the Attorney General of the
intervene in September 20th for governor
Faubus to appear in court to defend his
actions please understand that the
government at this time had no statutory
authority to intervene in the state so
the judgment invitation to the dosage
department was crucial on Wednesday
September 11th 1957 Arkansas Congressman
Brooks Hayes offered to arrange a
meeting between eisner and fathers and
Eisenhower agreed to meet despite the
opposition of attorney general brownell
then the president proceeded to stage
manage the event he phoned brownells to
dictate specific wording that fall of us
was to include in his telegram asking
for the meeting Hayes talked on the
phone with White House chief of staff
Sherman Adams and he recalled that quote
it required a little negotiation a few
extra calls as I remember to get the
exact language that the president wanted
oh cool later press secretary James
Hagerty carried the Paullus telegram to
life now in the golf course the
president stepped down as a golf cart
and composed an answer haggar be
announced as the governor's telegram had
reached the White House quote without
advance notice uncle when reporters
asked the book whoops Hayes had a role
in setting up the meeting James Hagerty
said none that I know of of course a
modern press secretary would never
manipulate the truth like that with it
but when the morning of saturday
September 14th arrived i snared the
system and whitman reported a great
princy at the Newport White House the
tallest party arrives in a helicopter in
850 a.m. after some informal talk
Eisenhower took governor Faubus into his
office and closed the door and for the
next 20 minutes the two men SAT alone
governor Faubus later complained that
Eisenhower election
him quote like a general tells a
lieutenant unquote he remembered saying
and saying in effect this is the way it
is and this has got to be done and
that's got to be done Eisenhower offered
the government governor a face-saving
solution changed the orders of the
National Guard troops preventing
integration to protecting the students
in entering the school and Eisenhower
issued an ultimatum and this is
according to fall this he said no one
would benefit from the trial of strength
between the president and the governor
if the Arkansas governor opposed federal
authority the state would lose follow us
in the president's de mer joined a group
that included attorney general brown ale
and Congressman Hayes notice that pelvis
looked unhappy that his grim expression
indicated just talked to the president
had been slow going now as an Grinnell
Sloan knows so well I often permitted
her father to take the heat while he
kept himself above the print so the
president pretending neutrality at this
in this larger meeting turned to
brownell that herb can't you go down
there and ask the court to postpone the
implementation of this order for a few
days ten days the three weeks and
conference was in whatever time it might
be decided it's best to solve the
problem brownell responded no that's
impossible it isn't legally possible now
I assure you Dwight Eisenhower I knew
what her Brunell would say before he
spoke father's lizard Sherman Adams
recalled in inscrutable silence during
this long meeting I've now produced a
letter from a businessman who had
advised him to remove every southern
officer from command in the army because
they were going to stage a revolution
over this very City as the condition for
holding the meeting Eisenhower had
required that the parties issue
statements afterwards cleared of course
with the prison it took more than two
hours to get a statement from fulvous a
very unsatisfactory one with Brooks
Hayes negotiating the language with
Sherman
on the phone nevertheless eisenhower
believed that governor palmas had
capitulated I definitely got the
understanding he wrote that he was going
back to Arkansas to act within a matter
of hours to revoke his orders to the
guard to prevent re-entry of the Negro
children into the school the governor
fallin returned to Arkansas and did
nothing leaving the National Guard with
orders to prevent integration Eisenhower
was furious brownout recalled the
president's temper he said he would
start getting red from the neck up and
he certainly knew all the right curse
words iclone brownell you were right he
said all this broke his word on Friday
September 20th judge Davies our fathers
defeat has defined in response publish
was through the National Guard unless
the states of the southern Governor's
Conference in Georgia leaving the
students at the school at the mercy of a
growing mob concept on Monday September
23rd chaos reigned at Central High
School the mob intercepted four black
news men a mob leader called out killed
of kills of several men beat two of the
reporters during the melee age of the
black students slipped into a side door
of the school a woman saw doesn't scream
oh my god they're going in the [ __ ]
are in she fell to her knees and covered
her face I'm mob ringleader balance come
on let's go in the school of drag them
out a white girl ran down the street and
shouted hysterically the [ __ ] got in
they tricked us the [ __ ] got in the
police arrested the girl and protest
leaders cried look at that they arrest a
white girl and let the [ __ ] in our
school of court at 344 p.m. Eisenhower
received a frantic wire from mayor
Woodrow Wilson man who declared that our
vaca versus followers had agitated
aroused and assembled the mob
Eisenhower's rage is still evident in
his memoirs quoted the issues have
become the issue has now become most
clear
in fact and in law cruel mob course had
frustrated the execution of the order of
a United States Court note that of a
united states court and the governor of
the state was sitting by refusing to
lift a finger to support the local
authorities there was only one
justification for the use of troops
Eisenhower continued to uphold the law
so far most United I as president of the
united states now have that
justification in the clear obligation to
act brownell at Eisenhower's Direction
drafted three documents a statement
approximation and an address to zation
the statement quoted the president quote
i will use the full power of the united
states including whatever force may be
necessary to prevent any obstruction of
the law and to carry out the orders of
the federal court the proclamation
ordered a name the resistance the cited
precedents of the use of truth the 1790
law I do feel all that George Washington
had used to put down the whiskey
rebellion and Grover Cleveland's use of
an 1807 law to enforce the federal
injunction against the labor strikes but
the document excluded left out an
extraordinary President Abraham
Lincoln's use of force against himself
in the Civil War 2 z's September 24th
was the day of decision that morning Ike
review these military options army chief
of staff general Maxwell Taylor referred
the National Guard to army troops but
Eisenhower overruled him the President
did not trust the Arkansas guard
recalling a civil war adage he worried
that the use of Arkansas units might tip
brother against brother Eisenhower
waited to see if the proclamation would
be amazed he received the second frantic
telegram from layer man in Little Rock
the immediate need for federal troops is
urgent man wrote people are converging
on the scene from all directions mob is
arms and engage in fisticuffs and other
acts of violence situation is out of
control employees cannot disperse the
moth
the 12 08 p.m. I've now announced that
he would sign the order for the federal
troops to go to Little Rock at
twelve-fifteen he called a general
Taylor to tell him he and chosen a force
he knew would be loyal the hundreds of
1st airborne division now there was
nostalgia as well as military
calculation in that choice Eisenhower
had paid a legendary visit to the 100
first just before d-day when he expected
up to seventy percent of them to die
until they were special to him and these
troops and anticipation there's a long
story of this with anticipation of
unrest in the South had already been
trained to handle riders they would
remain on duty until the situation was
stabilized and then be replaced by
federalized National Guard troops the
first of 52 aircraft carrying
approximately 1,000 troops departed from
Campbell Air Force Base in Kentucky at
three-thirty p.m. at 640 p.m. 26
vehicles carrying the men was honored
and first arrived at Central High School
the soldiers disembarked carrying
carbines and billy clubs for the first
time in 80 years federal troops patrol
on the ground in a former Confederate
state a few minutes before nine p.m.
Eastern Time Eisenhower a turd the Oval
Office wearing a gray suit with a blue
shirt and tie he sat down flanked by the
portraits of Benjamin Franklin George
Washington Abraham Lincoln and robert e
lee the president stared down with
manuscript typed in large print on sic
papers then he looked into the cameras
and began commenting that instead of
speaking from Rhode Island he had chosen
to return quote to the house of Lincoln
of Jackson enough Wilson to reinforce
the furnace with which I intend to
pursue this course until the orders of
the federal court a little rock can be
executed without unlawful interference
think about that Eisenhower's consistent
stance on civil rights to the dismay of
his liberal critics
had been to a woman saying anything that
would inflame feelings in the south yet
at this moment with soldiers on the
ground in Arkansas Eisenhower chose to
identify with the presidents who had
made bloody war on the seventh to
reinforce the permanence of his decision
the president was speaking he said from
the house of lincoln eisenhower that
defender of the courts declared quote
mob rule cannot be allowed to override
the decisions of our courts if Arkansas
citizens ended their resistance the
troops would no longer be necessary the
president concluded with the closing
words of the Pledge of Allegiance that
he had personally penciled in as a final
draft one nation indivisible with
liberty and justice for all the
newspaper noted that the president had
left out under God meanwhile in Little
Rock melba pattillo was jolted awake by
the doorbell and loud voices melba's
mother Lois put her hand over her
daughter's mouth emotions her to get up
the doorbell kept ringing her
grandmother picked up a shotgun and
called out the lizard she whispered to
her family white moon is white men
wearing black hats what are they doing
on our front porch at this time of night
then she called to the door state your
business gentlemen are we forced to do
mine they respond skinny we're from the
Office of the President of the United
States please open your door we have a
message from your president the man is
great displays identification and told
melva's mother let your daughter go back
to school and she will be protected the
next morning a new york times reporter
described a scene at Central High School
as chillin the forest of law shows naked
Lee on the point of a bayonet he
observed a crowd of 1,500 gathered the
troops dispersed troops as soon as they
formed a soldier accidentally pricked
the man with a bayonet another man tried
to
wrestle a rifle from soldier and the
sergeant struck him on the head with
rifle but at 925 am 40 minutes after the
bell signaling the start of school
Chiefs arrived and 30 soldiers
accompanied the nine students up the
wide steps and into the high school
shortly after Kenny and police received
a call claiming that a bomb had been
planted in the school a second phone
message led to a temporary evacuation of
the building outside agitators taunted
the soldiers a woman Laura lowered their
car windows of Christ hio Hitler to the
soldiers of the division that captured
Hitler's refuge in Germany a bus driver
opened his door and yelled all you need
now is a Russian flag a man stood on the
steps and announced gentlemen you have
just observed how the communist
dictatorship works by mid bed the crowd
around the school had dwindled to 25 by
the second day of school the mob had
disappeared now while the soldiers did
their duty their commander-in-chief
releases stress with golf Eisenhower in
that Steffensen that was what golf most
of him I mean he loved to do it but they
did was this stress reliever and he
played 18 holes of golf in practice
cutting chipping and driving for almost
two additional hours meanwhile orval
faubus had returned to Arkansas and
announced we are now an occupied
territory on sep tember 26 the
administration's fears of a larger
conflict in the South produced an
embarrassing gaffe the army announced
that unit the quote throughout the
southern states had been placed on
special alert to deal with any possible
outbreaks in connection with school
segregation unquote now that
announcement set off a political
firestorm James Hagerty told the press
that the President had immediately
revoked the order that he had not
authorized the alert nor did he know
about it until appeared appear
on the news wires I personally have my
doubts that that has all happens without
eisner is okay but that's what the
integrity said and he always told the
truth of course that same day Eisenhower
ecigs us received a telegram from
Senator Richard Russell of Georgia
Russell alleged that the war hero of
Europe had ordered the troops in Little
Rock to use quote tactics that must have
been copied from the manual issues to
the officers of Hitler's stormtroopers
unquote the senator accused Eisenhower
of appointing employing strong-arm
totalitarian police state methods in
Little Rock now that red plush must have
crept up Eisenhower's neck once again
but his response was reasonably
restrained at Exxon Abraham Lincoln
asserting that quote failure to act in
such a case would be tantamount to
acquiescence in anarchy and dissolution
of the Union I must say I completely
failed understand he wrote your
comparison of our troops to Hitler's
stormtroopers in one case military power
was used to further the ambitions and
purposes of a ruthless dictator in the
other to preserve the institutions of
pre governments some southerners
threatened civil war senator Allen
Johnston center roland johnson of south
carolina call for quote warrant to be
issued for the arrest of federal
soldiers responsible for unnecessary
bludgeoning of arkansas citizens and
unlawful invasion of their homes in
johnston urged governor Faubus to
proclaim a state of insurrection in
force a showdown with the president by
calling out the arkansas national guard
himself others were more positive one of
the martin luther king jr who wrote the
president the overwhelming majority of
southerners Negro and white standing
stand firm behind your resolute action
and Luis Satchmo Armstrong says the
press the most colorful telegram daddy
if and when you decide to take those
little Negro children personally in the
Central High School
along with your marvelous troops please
take me along eisenhower gave up on his
vacation it was never much of a vacation
and returned to Washington at an October
third news conference the president
insisted that he had sent the troops not
to enforce integration but to support
the cords these ports he said are not
here merely to enforce integration the
heath courts are our bulwarks our shield
against autocratic government now some
historians have concluded that this
terrible language meant that Ike was
opposed to desegregation which you have
to note carefully what the courts he
defended were enforcing what they were
enforcing was not segregation it was not
plessy v ferguson eisenhower was
supporting the court in the of course
but in the enforcement of brown however
cautiously he praised it I've never
believed politically that the
southerners were more likely to respond
to an appeal to obey the law then to a
sermon declaring the evils of
segregation in he said to the premise
there is a great very great division on
the destiny of the races in the United
States how they should act particularly
when we come into the social aspect of
our lives as opposed merely to the
economic and illegal but those corals
will eventually be settled the
population itself on the whole will
remember it's respect for long and it
will be settled on that basis to add to
the president's burdens little rock was
shoved off the front pages on October
fourth by the news that the Soviet Union
and successfully launched a satellite
into space now by this time the
president's political adversaries had
begun to propagate them in that
Eisenhower had acted in decisively in
little rock in Hubert Humphrey stated
what would become senator Hubert
Humphrey from minnesota state of weapons
become the conventional wisdom i'd only
regret
he wrote that the president was so slow
and grasping the true nature of the
situation that troops had to be called
out the Democratic Party's Advisory
Council which included a life Stevenson
and Harry Truman also called
Eisenhower's actions indeed sightings of
course the council made no mention of
Governor father's the Democrats who had
precipitated the crisis aiza our years
later still resented this criticism from
quote some of the Great's liberals the
Democratic Advisory Committee or
whatever they call it in the 1967
interview Ike noted the president john f
kennedy has the same problem at the
university of mississippi in 1962
cannonade he grumbled had a couple of
people killed but the Democratic
Advisory Committee didn't say a damn
word about it we must remember that
Eisenhower could have chosen not to send
troops to the wrong if mob violence was
the issue father's and his National
Guard troops would have kept in peace
the real issue with resistance to a
federal court order for school
desegregation the segregation scented
segregationist understood that Senator
Herman Talmadge of Georgia later comment
that Eisenhower after all was the
general a professional politician might
have back down but not Ike when he
called in the federal troops to
integrate the school we knew he meant
business Eisenhower's decision in Little
Rock reinforced the great verdict of the
Civil War the supremacy of federal
authority including federal court orders
over the city as the segregationists
knew the time was on their side in
Little Rock Senator James Eastland of
Mississippi told the white Citizens
Council the use of the army will not win
because the soldiers cannot stay in
Little Rock all the time that was true
the president could not maintain an
endless occupation of even one school
let alone send troops to other trouble
spots throughout
south and the Little Rock crisis is not
really over they were court battles
throughout 1958 governor Faubus closed
the lorac high schools the following
year and there was nothing not the
government legally could do about that
on October 14 26 is 67th birthday
Eisenhower brownell and Secretary of the
army brucklier agreed to withdraw half
of the federal troops keeping 1800
National Guard soldiers under federal
control and release the rest Arkansas
I'm November eighteenth Eisenhower
authorized the recent withdrawal of the
remaining federal units by Thanksgiving
and on November twenty-fifth nineteen
fifty-seven just as the last of the
hundred and first airborne division
soldiers prepared to depart from Little
Rock and Whitman walked into the Oval
Office and found Eisenhower slumped over
his desk muttering incoherently the
president has suffered a stroke thank
you
[Applause]